stand-up comedian actor writer producer
and promoting his new film American
dreamer which will be in theaters on
demand on September 20th yes good to see
you good to see you you know I am most
excited for that kids father because
that kids father's like I you know he
probably thought I'm failing at being a
dad I mean it's like you're like do I
get him off this thing do I you know
forget it you know stop fighting and
then the kid wins that thing he's like
I'm the best dad ever
I'm the best dad but are you lenient
with your kids to play video games you
got five kids ya know there's a lot of I
think that a lot of parents would never
honestly admit how much screen time
their kids engage in it so it's a I feel
like I did a tweet where like 90% of
parenting is just taking iPads away from
kids you know there's a lot of that but
I wouldn't say I always thought I'd be a
lenient dad but I'm much more of like my
dad just kind of like a bastard how much
material do you get out of family life
there's a lot I mean I make a point of
not inserting too much in my show
because I don't want to because I
remember being the the guy in my 20s and
seeing people talk about their wife or
husband and kids and just going I can't
get a date what are they talking about
so I intentionally don't bring up a lot
of kids material but does your wife who
gives you the most material that you're
able to use in your stand-up you know I
guess it's some of it is my kids but I
think some of it the biggest source of
material is anger you know thing why are
you angry because you know it's hard to
be me no I think that there's we learned
about being Jim Gaffigan you seem like a
nice Midwest guy I you know there but
there's a lot of anger underneath there
right you have a lot of anger it's a
little bit yeah I'm Midwest I'm from
Ohio
yeah I mean it's like we have to it has
to come out as passive-aggressive
behavior
well I just yell at those guys
and you can yell at those guys right by
the way the diversity on this show is
we've like a Benetton ad I mean we
recheck the box it's like well there's a
guy with tattoos they all have it's like
everyone is wearing glasses too may have
weak eyesight you made this show even
whiter Jim I know I'm the whitest hi by
the way can I just you know men are
gross by the way but you know I was at
the I was at the pool this weekend cuz I
have kids I would never go to the pool
otherwise as men get older profoundly
grosser profoundly grosser I saw a guy
at the pool he had a shirt off he looked
like a first draft of a human like it
was rather I felt like I was like is
that a Simpsons character or an actual
guy walking by he's here right now
Fritzi stand up it's it's all good I
can't imagine you at the pool I know I
know I'm not supposed to be no outside
no but you do these that I saw where's
your what you're famous for and one of
the things is being pale yes it's not a
great that's like you didn't accomplish
it no it's it's no it's not that's a
great point it's a recessive gene it's
something that you know you know I felt
tortured with as a child and you can't
really establish any kind of pride
around it you can't be like hey I'm
proud to be white you can't do that so I
just you know but yeah it is a source
and I think of humor and there's a lot
of pale people it's it's kind of
compared to like other struggles it's
nothing but like you know for pale
people it's rough
who was the comedian you first heard or
watched and you went I'd like to do that
I think I think that Jonathan winters
was one of my all-time favorites where
he was he kind of embodied the whole
kind of a conversation you know doing
these characters
but I think Letterman was a huge
influence and Bill Murray definitely
like kind of sarcastic but in kind of a
way where like Letterman was embodied
kind of making fun of things or making
fun of someone but they were in on the
joke and you remember your first
Letterman appearance oh yeah I remember
it was it was something that it went
like that and it was one of those things
where I'd I was saying it over and over
in my mind the night before because it
was I mean I'm from Indiana and that was
like my overall goal was to appear on
Letterman because he's from India yeah
and he was the guy that I would watch on
TV growing up in a small town in India
and I'm like oh you can get out of here
yeah I mean I was like oh wow I could
maybe do something and then you want
Dave to laugh
how how where are you if Dave is
laughing when you're doing your stand-up
you're very aware because you know his
laugh and also pause laugh very unique
and it's weird because you know like
performing on Letterman was because I
did it so many times there was kind of a
there's a certain kind of relationship
you established where he kind of like
sometimes you'd be on the show and he'd
just look at you like go you know like
he's like I'm not in the mood for this
just people you just started saying some
jokes which I could appreciate cuz he
did it for so long and you know I think
there were a couple years there where
he's like I don't know why I'm doing
this just keep talking but when you that
when you hear laughs like how active is
that oh it's an incredibly addictive I
think it's more addictive coming up with
new material like are a new line so like
I have new matera which is special which
is different from my recent special and
so coming up with new lines I think I
you know I've never tried heroin but I
imagine it's that close where it's you
know it it drives you you know to kind
of come up with new material and it
there's a sense of accomplishment and
then I can just go and overeat and I
feel fine
but do you I said this to Jonah Hill one
time and it didn't go over well
he lost all that weight yeah and I said
do people look at you differently like
you're not as funny yeah because you're
you're in shape or you lost this weight
and and I he took it the wrong way I
didn't mean it as a negative as much as
how people perceive you like Brad Pitt
you don't want to see him be funny
because he he's Brad Pitt he looks great
like we don't want good-looking guys to
also be funny I don't think so I think
that I mean obviously there's exceptions
me yes no but I think that there is
something about I don't think we want to
see good-looking people complain I think
or like even when like a good-looking
person kind of does the self-deprecating
thing you're kind of like come on here I
mean like they're digging real deep I
hate my wrist my wrists are so wristy
and you're just thinking why don't you
cut them yeah I mean it's like but there
is so like I think the struggles of you
know the the human experience is and I
think that it's so rare for men to be
even attractive I think it's it's like
when there's like a brad pitt people are
kind of like alright you get to be
good-looking but he was really good in
once upon a time oh really Tarantino
movie yeah I'm sure he's I mean he was
very funny yeah I have no doubt that
he's funny I've met him but sometimes
the guy who you don't expect to be funny
is funnier because of that does that
make sense yeah I think George Clooney
is really funny too but I think also
there is I think that generally humans
and also the entertainment industry puts
people in categories like you played a
priest now you're just gonna play a
priest you know I mean so and I guess we
do that you know in general to people
weren't you a football player were you a
football player in high school I was in
high school were you any good I was all
right I was the captain the year my
brother
I adore bro older brother and we had we
were undefeated we won like 32 games in
a row and we also had a school that was
a hundred students and we also had a
soccer team so it was like really
exceptional and there were girls too and
so it was really exceptional for the
football team to be good but it was just
as a short stretch where it was really
good and that was because there were a
bunch of families that had like two kids
so like me and my brother worthy I was
the center and he was the tackle
we were both the defensive ends and then
two other brothers were one was a tight
end and one was the wide receiver and
one was a quarterback one was the
running back it was like for families
but ya know football was a big thing I
mean I you know do you have a do you
root for the cult I do I do root for the
Colts but I'm not I can't do the commit
I mean I I played football you're
showing that Purdue thing I walked on
there and I look at that hair I know if
that was nice back then you were golden
boy I was I had hair you don't do
steroids anymore not anymore okay and
but it was just too much of so like
after I like there was like probably
four or five years where I didn't watch
football at all after I quit I was like
I can't deal with it and then I enjoy it
but it's it's it's a commitment also
when you have children I do you know
there's also you know it's keeping up
with all the information I know this is
what you guys do all the time but I'm
like I can't look I was hanging around
I was talking to Seinfeld last night
he's watching the Mets named
name-dropping yeah well that's the whole
thing it's like it's like also it's like
I grew up listening I know all the
baseball players now I couldn't name to
Mets I couldn't name to Mets because you
have kids well I think that and I'm just
I don't know Louis would you rather your
kids got into sports or comedy oh that's
a good point I think sports was really
important for keeping me out of trouble
so yeah I would say sports I would say
sports because
comedy is it's supposed to be the
hardest thing right life is it the
hardest thing I don't know if it's the
hardest thing it's just the
entertainment industry is so it's such a
fluke all of us sitting in here were in
the entertainment industry and we have
these amazing jobs but it is in a way a
fluke like there's there's hundreds of
people that would love to do what we do
and but it's just it's this strange
navigation thing where it's like I
always talk about it like Dead Poets
Society you know like there was the evil
dad who was like don't go into acting
it's like now I look at that dad and I'm
like you know he was right it's like the
odds are really small wait the kid who
killed himself right yeah his dad his
dad was a little dark there Jim his dad
was a good guy he was yeah it was right
you almost quit no no I didn't I always
I kind of resigned myself there was a
couple years where I was like all right
I guess I'm the weird uncle that does
stand-up that lives in a dirty apartment
and at least I get to do what I like you
know but ya know I didn't really see
because there was an enjoyment coming up
with new jokes and and there is that
feedback of doing stand-up do you know
that there's one joke you can always go
to let's say you've had two that fall
they fall flat then you then you just go
alright I'll go through the rolodex and
I can come back with a hammer well
you're always working on new material so
when I'm doing my longer theater shows I
usually will either do an encore or end
with this chunk this like seven or eight
minute chunk on Hot Pockets that will
kind of clean it up my kids that's where
I first learned about you with your
stand-up was hot pocket I know yes and I
I came in the next day with these guys I
said my daughter said dad you got to
watch this guy and then she started
singing oh yeah yeah where did that come
from I you know that was that was back
you know it's an old joke it's back
when they first introduced them or they
first started advertising them and it
was the worst commercial I've ever seen
and the jingle was so basic and but it
was one of those things like I saw it as
the next level of like you know the
7-eleven frozen burrito but I I didn't
know I didn't know that it was gonna be
kind of the meal that every teenager or
single guy was gonna eat I just it was
just I had a bunch of jokes on it and it
just started taking off I want you to
listen to this fritzy has a now he's
done stand-up okay sent four times all
right in five years okay so he's really
been out there not not that consistent
okay this is his signature bit okay and
I just this was at Caroline's okay so
this is Monday night open mic six
o'clock fritzy is on the stage at
Caroline's so I'm at a sporting event
the other night and at least three
different people come over to me asking
if I'm sitting in their seats so I don't
know if it's a few guys ever deal with
this or you go to a concert or sporting
events how difficult is to [ __ ] seats
and concert or a sporting event think
about it it's got all the information
you need right there on the ticket
section row seat number section row C
number it's really really not that
complicated I've got these people coming
over to me and saying I think we're in
the same sea not only they not in my
seats they're all the way on the other
side of they really couldn't have been
further from where I'm at so I don't
understand section row seat let's let's
get it together people I just can't do
an entire bit that's that's interesting
no no I think it's well I see that
there's a comic idea there right yeah
and there's something probably Universal
about it but maybe it's you know and
obviously it was funny you know you
probably told and it was Universal when
you talk to people about it you're like
people keep asking and it was quiet in
Carolina and it was based on a true
story but some of it is that might be
something shared by people that go to
sporting events but not everyone goes to
shore
the guys like to remind me there's
interesting observation and
observational humor yeah there was some
humor any observations yeah no that's
it's hard it's hard I know it but it's
but you could could you take that to the
next level maybe I would I would I would
have started and said you know I don't
know why what what it is about me but
people always think I'm sitting in their
seat okay and then I would say you know
because it is it does happen but I don't
go to that many sporting events so does
does it happen that often it does to me
then it's kind of a commentary on how
people are just too lazy to look at
their tickets that's that's the
observation it's like like how do these
people get here like what are they you
know instead of in Madison Square Garden
are they sometimes like just in the
Wendy's near door your next door going
aren't the next bush the film is
American dreamer and theaters and on
demand September 20th
you're a down on your luck driver yes
and you take extra cash you're driving
around low-level drug dealers yes and
one drug dealer and then you get in
trouble I get in trouble you find
trouble well I'm this guy who's you know
we're all kind of a couple bad decisions
away from you know being in a precarious
situation and this is a story about that
guy who starts driving around this drug
dealer and he's kind of sees that this
drug dealer has this money and he
decides to kidnap the drug dealers kid
not a great idea not a great idea and so
but the movie kind of looks it it's a
thriller so I don't want to give too
much away because but it is amazing you
should see the trailer should you see
the Train are you a tough guy
no I but I play a guy who's pretty he
you know he starts off normal like you
know we've all been in an uber and
you're like that seems like a norm
what's his story and then as the movie
goes on you're like oh I can't believe I
ever rooted for this guy so it's one of
those people in other words it's like
it's like everyone you know
yeah you look tough on the poster I look
tough i intimidating right look at that
so that's pretty that's pretty
intimidating a lot of makeup on there a
lot of well you know they darken my beer
I know this is a dark in your face -
yeah they actually got a tan I look like
it that could be like you know London's
fallen you know I mean I could be like
they're our Butler Jer is it Gerard or
Jared iclone Gerard I call him Jared
okay I call it or Jerry I act like I'm
gonna know Jerry Butler who's your most
famous friend aside from Seinfeld which
you reminded us you know it's um I don't
know I don't I don't really uh I don't
really have that many friends
no I don't have famous friends I don't
think aside from Seinfeld I don't know I
mean there's friends that I hang out
with and then there's people I know
dear I mean like know if you were call
okay the most famous phone number you
have do you want mine so you have a
famous friend yeah I'll give you mine
no I will say I don't know you're
overthinking this you I am overthinking
it because I don't want to sound like a
jerk I don't know I have lived Shrivers
phone number I have it's good Kiefer
Sutherland's phone number yeah we're
talking now but you know usually
Kardashian do you know the car no I
don't know like party B anybody I know
cardi B I know I'd look like it'd look
like I'd be friends with cardi we're
just both from like the same background
and we're both into hip-hop you you're
both former strippers well you know I
prefer exotic dancer but good luck with
American dreamer
he's a Jim Gaffigan he's stand-up
comedian actor writer producer Vega and
decent guy thank you
father of five father of five anything
else
are you five and done are you done oh my
god I hope so
yeah no I mean I love my children but
they're they're killing me
yeah I mean you have a two-bedroom
apartment know that I did when I wrote
this book that is phat we had Adam which
was a good idea
but yet no it's just too much but I also
have a new special on amazon prime
quality time which you have to check out
okay but one wife five children
overweight what else do you need to know
and a couple of specials a couple of
specials you're living the American
dream it's all good American dreamer
he's Jim Gaffigan for morgue and Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]